sunset overdrive the recently announced
open-world action game from developer
insomniac Studios is a strange bird
indeed you're constantly bouncing on the
roofs of cars firing off explosive teddy
bears and generally causing havoc and
mayhem wherever you go all this is
wrapped up in a colorful punk-rock
aesthetic that as you're about to hear
draws its inspiration from some unlikely
sources together the style and substance
of sunset overdrive makes it a pretty
far cry from insomniacs more recent
games including the resistance series
and fuse so why the sudden shift from
cover based shooting to high-flying
action why jump from the apocalypse to
the awesome pocalypse to find the answer
and to learn more about the game we
traveled to insomniac headquarters to
speak with developers themselves and
take a behind-the-scenes look at the
making of sunset overdrive yeah I think
the first time we pitched this game it
was terrible there's an epic disaster
yeah it was basically we did it we did a
presentation we were like here's what
the game's gonna be like but we don't
wanna get bogged down in a story detail
so we're not gonna tell you who you're
fighting what you're fighting how you're
fighting but here's all the stuff that
we're really into here's like all this
crazy pop-culture mishmash for Halloween
masks talking about like like cultural
mashups and we had yeah literally slides
and slides of vintage vintage Halloween
masks and like Popeye cartoons I've got
so upset about that pop-up where you
can't talk about Popeye we've learned
over the years not to be afraid of
failure we fail all the time whether
it's on a grand scale or a micro scale
and but the key is never to stop trying
different things because then you
stagnate and you don't learn from your
failures and certainly on this project
we've got a lot of things that didn't
work we try things that maybe some
people felt would have been awesome and
other people felt like just didn't match
the either the tone or the basic
mechanics we were going for Marcus
Center while we were working on
resistance 3 you know had been talking
and they had this idea about a game that
they wanted to make
and and so that's really what it was it
was just an idea you know how would you
survive the end times
once the team at insomniac had rallied
behind a shared vision for the end of
the world or at least the end of Sunset
City they had to actually start making
the game if you read GameSpot's preview
for sunset overdrive that went up last
week by the way then you already have a
sneak peak of what this game will entail
but in case you missed it the basics are
thus energy drinks are evil okay okay
there's more to it than that as sunset
overdrive is all about mixing fast-paced
reversal with insomniacs signature
gunplay the result is a game that wants
you in constant motion dispensing death
as you hop between grind rails and off
of restaurant awnings
however making all these pieces the
shooting the rail grinding the unusual
the bouncy car roofs all fit together
into one cohesive whole wasn't an easy
task when the game really kind of
crystallized I think for me was when
traversal became started using traversal
in the game like it just wasn't about
walking around world and kind of you
know killing a bunch o deed it was about
killing o deed but doing in a really
stylish fashion like you know grinding
jumping up round and really you know
looking cool while you're doing it this
is a game where you actually interact
with the environment all the time and so
a lot more even than games like infamous
where you interact with the elements by
what climbing up buildings but most the
time you're up in the air you're out
doing stuff this is a lot more like Tony
Hawk where the entire world has to be
built with how the gameplay mechanics
work so there just ends up being so much
tied together that we really couldn't
box them up and kind of develop them
independently when working on weapons
and sunset overdrive you know we have to
take kind of an approach of looking at a
couple different things that take into
account how fast the player can move as
well as making sure that they're getting
a good experience out of the weapon
itself and so you know what that means
is we have kind of an immune system that
allows the player to be a little bit
looser to make up for the fact of how
fast that they're moving but at the same
time a lot of our weapons have you know
AOE aspects to handle how fast you can
move so you can be a little sloppier or
a little bit of auto targeting or homing
to help you be a little bit sloppier so
you can move really fast but you still
have to do most of the work and then it
gets you that extra 10
percent of the way there or we have
things that are like status affects
setting groups of dudes on fire or
freezing them things like that so like
really help to you know manage the crowd
a little bit we've got more interviews
in this game that we've had at any game
we've ever released yeah I mean it is
one of those things when you look at the
game you know some people might might
think that you know it's like a kids
game you know because it's so colourful
and but we wanted to juxtapose that with
with kind of a more mature aesthetic in
terms of the tone in terms of the you
know we call it a satire it's not really
a comedy game and I think the difference
between you know a comedy game and a
satire is you know we have this mantra
or beyond where we we said okay don't
try to make jokes make comments when you
embrace irreverence when you embrace
this idea that you're not being bound to
real world rules or trying to tell a
story that takes itself completely
seriously then anything's possible
and that's what's been really fun for us
on the ratchet series for example and is
absolutely a blast for everybody on
sunset overdrive because sunset
overdrive involves this world that isn't
playing by our standard rules where we
can take the story in unexpected
directions and do some crazy stuff armed
with its irreverent tone outrageous
weapons and insane visual style sunset
overdrive is shaping up to be a
refreshing departure from the CIO's more
recent more serious projects of course
there's still plenty more to detect in
this upcoming open-world action game so
be sure to stay tuned again spot comm
for all the latest updates on the game